Development can be divided into six main stages on the timeline. Prenatal,
infancy childhood, adolescence, adulthood and finally late adulthood. Within
these stages there are domains or topics that psychologists are interested in.
This focuses in the changes in our neurological structures in the brain. Then
we have Sensory Development. This focuses on how our senses change as we
develop. For example, how our vision develops. We also look at our physical and
motor development. This looks at the development of our physical movement and
body control. For example, when you crawl or walk. We also look at our
cognitive development. This domain focuses on our ability to think, solve
problems, learn new things and remember things. And finally, our social and
emotional development. This focuses on things like attachment and how infants
form attachments. And how those attachments will affect future relationships.
These are just some of the aspects developmental psychologists are interested
in. In this lesson, we'll go through each of the major stages of development,
and discuss the changes during them. Some psychological domains are going to be
more important in certain stages than in others. So, we might not go over all
six domains in each stage of life, but we'll definitely touch on each of them.
So, with that said, why don't we go on to see how these psychological processes
unfold from conception to death.